foreign
Oregon and talk to Jose what's up Jose
how you doing I'm good como estas
thank you for taking my call you betcha
man how can I help brother
yeah so my question is
um
you're good man take a minute take a
minute
how do how do I stop grieving somebody
that's alive
oh man that's a heavy one
tell me about it
so
basically it's uh
it's my dad he was uh
he was a quarterback when I was 14. so
about 14 years ago and jeez man
um
yeah I mean I've had a lot of things
happen you know from that point on and
I mean I'm 29 now and
um
basically I have decided that it's time
to work on my
um depression so
you know he's in Mexico and
um I talked to him you know weekly or
but it's been like this for so many
years that our conversations are like a
minute long and
um I only see him maybe once a year if
that
um
so he's part of my life but at the same
time he's not because
um
because he's not in my life anymore you
know yeah and so does he does he want to
be does he like the phone calls are they
getting awkward
they're just I mean it's just so short
it's like hey how are you doing good
yeah um what are you doing going to work
okay I'll talk to you tomorrow yeah
and so I just feel like
you know I mean he's alive and I can see
him you know once a year even I know
some people don't even get that so I'm
great hey hold on don't compare your
grief to somebody else
here's why
that 14 year old little boy needed his
dad
and he got ripped out
and that 15 year old boy and that 18
year old boy and that 25 year old boy
and I'm telling you I'm in my 40s and I
still need my old man
okay there's no apologizing for that
brother
that's your dad
and when you say I need to work on my
depression I get the sentiment but I
want you to be careful about that
language because that suggests like I
need to work on my engine of my car
because my car is broken
your depression brother comes naturally
because your father got taken from your
home when you were 14 years old
and so your body shut the system down so
that the thing would keep operating
right it's like when your car overheats
it will turn itself off sometimes
right and so you're not broken man
your body's been trying to survive
without the Padre for a long time
are you a dad now
yeah how old is your kids
uh they're four and three okay uh the
reason I asked that is I was expecting
their you'd have young kids here's why
as you if you're like me dude when you
had kid number one it was kind of a
whirlwind you had kid number two you
start to feel your heart expand in a way
that you didn't know was possible
and you realize the capacity for love
that you didn't know is humanly capable
especially within your knuckle-headed
chest right and then you start to think
oh my dad felt that too
and then there's this it's like when you
get older you feel this different
compassion for your parents because you
realize they were hurting too and they
wanted to do it right and they messed up
too and they didn't know what day it was
either and the whole thing just gets
Messier and Messier and bigger this is
called wisdom and it's called
forgiveness and it's called just expand
you're just going through a natural
moment in your life
and if your dad was with you it's when
you start being like all right he just
runs his mouth about politics that's
fine but we're gonna go get tacos anyway
he just runs his mouth about whatever
we're gonna go I'm gonna take him out to
dinner anyway because you have a
different level of compassion challenge
you have is you can't see them
when you say you get to see them once a
year do you go home to Mexico to see
them
right yeah how are those trips
I mean it's it's
they're quick short I mean it's
expensive I can only take
like one of the kids so it's just
it's like it's
it's a lot to go see him basically like
I have to go through a lot to get down
there so it's not like
it's just quick and short it's like over
the weekend or
you know maybe three days and then you
know I'm back home so it's
difficult basically and then
you know I the last I took my daughter
um because he you know she's two years
old and he hadn't he hadn't even seen
her in
you know she does she doesn't know him
so she you know didn't want to be around
him you know she didn't want to and yeah
he's just an old strange man right right
and so it's just I don't know it's just
been like I know when I try to talk
about the kids I feel like he just uh I
feel like he shuts down so and I'll tell
you this brother he has to it doesn't
surprise me at all I say that he doesn't
have to that's not fair he didn't have
to
but he lost his son 14 years ago
right and it doesn't it doesn't it
doesn't
it doesn't compute that he would open up
his heart again for the chance to get
hurt that bad again
it also isn't an excuse right
like he's he's Granddad he I mean that's
his job is to open up his heart
humongous and let these little grandkids
Swan Dive into it but I get that's hard
right
I get that
it's not not excuse but it's a context
right so here's
I can give you a couple of nuts and
bolts man but I think there's a a
a a 30 000 foot view of this that we
need to take but first
um
I think you don't Grieve Your Dad
I think you grieve the picture of what
you wanted it to be
because your dad's still there
it's awkward it's weird those phone
calls are kind of perfunctory
and in a weird way he doesn't know you
like he could have because he hasn't
seen you for 50 he hasn't like hung out
with you and been like I had a paternal
role in your life for 15 years right so
I get there's some awkwardness there
um so what we're grieving is not Dad
dad's there we're grieving this picture
that Fathers and Sons are supposed to be
able to hang out together and have
dinner together and bicker and complain
with one another and challenge each
other to arm wrestling matches and
debate politics and roll their eyes that
you know that's they're supposed to be
able to do that
that's what I'm grieving
but I lost all that all that got ripped
away
and then when I grieve that then I can
be about okay what's given the the
reality that I live in I'm gonna choose
to live in reality what can I make of
this this season and that looks like
this what I'm going to tell you is going
to sound silly
but I've seen it work over and over and
it's pretty magical
if you kept a small little law keep it
on your phone and the notes app on your
phone
but if you kept just a series of
questions that when your kid does a
thing
like why do you do that
or what do you think about this or you
see something about Mexico on the news
and you're like I wonder what if you
kept a list of that
and every time you talk to your dad
there was some intention to that phone
call not just a like we're punching our
card like phone call made phone call
answered goodbye instead of that but it
was like Dad my kid keeps doing X do you
have any wisdom for me
dads struggle so much with feeling
like why don't people like me
and for you to reach out and say hey
what do you think about this I don't
know a dad in the world that doesn't
love giving wisdom they often give it
when it's not even asked for but if a
kid comes and asks Dad hey what do you
think god dude that's just like a gift
and so do you need that wisdom probably
not probably not
but man a you'll give your your your
putting oil in the engine of that
relationship
you're giving him something to think
about between calls
he may go look up something he may go
have some conversations at home
and this is not going to be the
conversation that I mean the
relationship that you wanted the one
where you hug him and y'all have dinner
together once a week
but it is going to be a different
version of what you have now
it may be down the road you say hey can
you do FaceTime with me I want to see
your face
and it might be completely new maybe
I've done that maybe you haven't but
it's you being vulnerable and he might
say no it's too hard for him okay
so I actually have been thinking about
asking him
you know just questions like that but
and I don't know I guess I just hold
back just because I feel like he's just
gonna shut down he might get personal he
might but also this
if you reach out and say hey 14 years
ago you got ripped from my life I miss
you and now I've got my own kids and I
need you
and I know it's hard and maybe you write
this in a letter and send it to him
but I'm entering into a season where I
need my dad
I've needed my dad for 14 years but I
really need him now I need a partner in
this
and we can't see each other all the time
I don't have the money to come down all
the time whatever
but can we can I can I ask you some
questions on the phone can we talk can
we connect in that way can I we FaceTime
with me once every two weeks
and dude dads are awkward on the phone
I'm the worst I'm awkward on the phone
my kids don't like talking to me on the
phone they're just like all right Dad
like because I I just is I wish I could
be adventurous on the phone but I'm not
um so I wouldn't expect this to just
feel like a warm hug because it's not
it's a cheap substitute but at least
it's a substitute
and then I think long term the 30 000
foot view I was talking about
is you have to ask yourself over time
how do I reverse engineer the life I
want versus the one I'm living
what does that mean
is Portland Oregon the place for us long
term or can I move South and be closer
to the Border closer to home is that
possible is there another job I could
take is there a different training I
could get over time so that I can
potentially reconnect our families
you might not want to do that
I packed up and moved a thousand miles
away from my family right so that
doesn't not out of anger anything but it
isn't always practical that isn't always
the solution for everything but at least
it's you asking the broader question
how valuable is this relationship to me
what do I need to do to bring it closer
given the reality that we're in he's not
allowed back in the States
and on and on that way and but you begin
to take some ownership of it and then
when you decide no Portland Oregon is a
place for my family it's where We've Got
Roots it's where my wife is from it's
where my job is all that this is where
we are then you're owning reality you're
choosing to be where you are and there's
some peace to that still hurts but
there's some peace to that it doesn't
feel like you are being jerked around by
the government they took your dad Away
by the politicians over here by the
economics over here I make some choices
I'm choosing to live here
I'm choosing that and so as part of this
is about gaining ownership back that's
hard to do man
all that to say I don't really agree
with your dad here
and you agree this situation I think you
grieve the picture of what should have
been
a Granddad with his two little grandkids
just sitting on the front porch in a
rocket chair being fat being loud
complaining about stuff
and he's not he's thousands of miles
away
hurts man
and then I think you reach out you write
that letter to dad and say it's been 14
years and I need you are you in
that's a scary letter to write brother
but I think he's worth it I think you're
worth it and I think your kids having a
Granddad it's worth it too
thank you for the call my man